je vais toucher ma retraite le moment
venu
à taux plein je souhaite très bien sûr
que les générations qui viennent
puissent bénéficier de cette même
solidarité or si nous ne changeons rien
ce système de retraite il est perdu si
la réforme passe dès cet été il faudrait
cotiser un trimestre de plus par an pour
arriver à 43 ans pour les travailleurs
nés à partir de 1965 gouvernement qui
pourra a priori compter dans l'hémicycle
sur le soutien des républicains des
compromis ont été trouvés notamment
celui de l'âge de départ à la fête qui
devrait être 64 ans avec notamment le
soutien des républicains le président LR
Eric sutier annonce qu'il est prêt à
voter le texte du Gouvernement pour une
réforme juste qui sauve notre système de
retraite par répartition Éric Ciotti a
fait lui un petit pas de côté si j'ose
dire et moi je m'en félicite en disant
on souhaite ne pas être dans
l'obstruction et rappelons que la droite
a appelé un certain nombre de réformes
Florent berger le secrétaire général de
la CFDT lance lui un avertissement à la
première ministre on fera tout pour que
le gouvernement recule selon que Erics
petit cèdent ou pas au gouvernement on
n'a pas bien compris ce matin le point
d'atterrissage ou pas de toute façon
même si nous parlementaires sont
excellents et convaincs une partie de
l'hémicycle ça se terminera en 49-3
est-ce que le scénario 64 ans tient la
corde vous comprenez que je peux pas
faire les annonces avant la Première
ministre en tout cas mais c'est plutôt
ça vous me dites pas non en tout cas je
c'est pas d'ailleurs une annonce que je
fais puisque la première ministre le
président de la République eux-mêmes ont
ouvert la porte en disant que les 65 ans
n'étaient pas un totem on a l'impression
que c'est des batailles politiciennes on
a vu des gens dire qu'ils étaient contre
64 ans et qui maintenant disent qu'ils
sont pour ou qui pourrait signer pour
d'autres qui s'abstiennent et qui n'ont
pas le courage de se battre contre donc
on a compris on est plus dans la
rationalité on est dans l'exercice
politique parmi les autres pistes le
minimum retraite pourrait être réévalué
il passerait à 1200 euros pour une
carrière complète aujourd'hui cette
pension minimum s'élève à 75% du SMIC
après de 2 millions de Français qui ont
des carrières complètes et qui ont moins
de 1000 euros bruts par mois de retraite
c'est inacceptable on demande au
gouvernement que la perspective des 1200
euros ne soit pas réservées aux futurs
entrants mais soit bien réservé aussi
aux actuels retraités l'important c'est
de garantir aux Français qui pourront
continuer à bénéficier d'une retraite
dans un système par répartition et tous
les Français ils sont attachés et qui
puissent bénéficier d'une retraite digne
c'est pour ça qu'on veut les revaloriser
je vous rappelle que dans un monde à
plus 4 degrés dans 30 ans on se posera
plus la question de répartition
capitalisation 62 64
on est dans un moment d'injustice
sociale majeur il y a 20 ans les 500
premières fortunes françaises
représentées 5% du PIB à l'arrivée de
Macron c'est 25% aujourd'hui on est
au-delà des 40%. voilà on est dans ce
temps on a du gavage pour les uns où on
passionnant pour les autres on vous
dites je ne me vois pas arriver à la
retraite on va évoquer les questions des
cours anxiété par exemple est-ce que
c'est pas un peu moi que les enfants qui
naissent en 2023 on ne sait pas
aujourd'hui leur garantir l'habitabilité
de la planète dans 30 ans
tu as beaucoup de pognons alors pour te
dire j'en avais plus avant de faire
présidents
est-ce que vous avez beaucoup beaucoup
si vous avez beaucoup d'amis
vous avez préparé deux trois vannes ou
non je vais essayer mais je sais que
vous savez il y a des jeux auxquels il
faut pas jouer parce que vous vous
rendez compte que à côté il y a trop de
niveau quoi
vous devriez que le prendre lui il est
pas mal hein
et sinistre c'est le gros dossier avec
lequel
les amis deuxième question vous avez
honnête avec toi c'est c'est pas le
meilleur boulot pour avoir beaucoup
d'amis c'est pas les meilleurs boulots
que vous avez beaucoup d'amis
des vrais amis non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]